your breakfast may be getting more
expensive
across the board americans are paying
more for food
since last year the cost of bacon has
gone up by over 10 percent
6.2 percent for fresh fruit and 0.2
percent for cereal
it may not seem like a lot but all these
little increases add up
and it's not just food it's goods and
services across
the economy after years of low inflation
that hovered around two percent
the consumer price index the benchmark
measure of inflation
in the us jumped 4.2 percent in april
from the year before
these increases are often felt at the
grocery store which is why it's
affecting the price of your breakfast
this has created a lot of concern over
whether higher prices are a temporary
blip
or here to stay during this time of
reopening
we are likely to see some upward
pressure on prices
so here's why you're paying more for
your breakfast in whether the current
price jumps are a bellwether of
inflation to come
a major factor for increased food prices
is corn which is soared roughly 50
in 2021. even if you don't have corn
flakes for breakfast
many foods have ingredients derived from
the grain or come from animals who eat
it
corn makes up over 96 percent of all
animal feed grain production
in the us and around one-fifth of the
u.s crop is exported to other countries
like china right now the country is on a
corn buying binge
farmers are racing to fat millions of
hogs to replace the pigs it had to kill
during the 2020 outbreak of african
swine fever
it's expected to import about four times
more corn
in 2021 mostly from u.s farmers
on top of that drought in corn producing
regions in south america have led to
disappointing crop yields and logistical
problems
in argentina multiple years of drought
have made the parvana river too
shallow for boats fully loaded with
grain to pass from the country's
interior
to atlantic chipping lanes simply put
the higher demand for feed corn from
china and smaller supply from south
america means more expensive sausage and
bacon
but that's not all that corn is doing to
raise the price for your breakfast
it's also making it more expensive to
ship food across the country
about 10 percent of the gasoline
consumed in the united states is ethanol
which is made from corn so the rise in
price for the grain has contributed to
higher gas prices
but also finding truck drivers to move
the food has been difficult
shipping demand for truck freight has
risen as the economy has emerged from
lockdowns
to lure new recruits trucking companies
have raised pay
further driving up the price of shipping
kellogg's maker of cereal brands like
frosted flakes has said that higher
shipping costs have contributed to it
raising prices
and those shipping problems haven't
stopped at the water's edge
ocean freight has made it more expensive
to ship sugar whose price has risen over
3 percent
the global supply chain slowdown last
year as well as the closing of the suez
canal in march
have backed up shipping for months but
economists say food prices are not the
best indicator for tracking inflation
across the entire economy
there are a few reasons for that
according to senior wall street journal
economics writer john hilzenrath
it's a very goods oriented sector of the
economy as opposed to
a labor-oriented sector of the economy
like a service sector
where labor costs really drive the cost
of the product
a more telling indicator for broader
inflation might be what you're paying
for that same breakfast
at a restaurant while overall food
prices have jumped 2.4 percent from a
year ago
restaurant meals have gone up 3.8 one
reason is restaurants just have more
expenses
for example takeout trays became more
costly after a february winter storm
knocked out plastics production in texas
and another reason is the increased cost
of labor
rising vaccination rates easing
lockdowns and federal stimulus aid have
boosted consumer spending
yet employers including restaurant
owners are struggling to find workers
as the economy has rebounded so have
wages
but participation in the labor force has
flattened
you know some people moved out of dense
cities that were seen
seen as being unsafe because of the
pandemic and so as restaurants reopen
it might be a geographic problem that
there just might not be people
in the place and then we also have to
think about the policy effects so the
government has thrown a lot of money at
supporting workers who were affected by
the pandemic
and some workers at this point might
just be saying while they're still
getting
these unemployment benefits might be
saying you know what i don't have to
rush back to work
fast food restaurants have started to
offer perks like signing bonuses and
free college tuition in a bid to lower
hourly workers
all this adds up to pricier meals for
diners
i think most people would agree
that we want to see wages rising when
particularly for
lower skill low-income workers when
wages are rising that means they're
better off that means they're bringing
home bigger paychecks
what we don't want to see is wage
increases paired together with inflation
increases that start feeding on each
other
and leave workers actually worse off and
not better off
this effect known as a wage price spiral
contributed to the high inflation of the
1970s
but will history repeat itself the
federal reserve for its part has said
prices will correct as supply and demand
forces even out
these one-time increases in prices are
likely to have
only transitory effects on inflation for
now indicators that measure expectations
of inflation
like treasury bond yields remain low
suggesting people expect inflation to be
modest
at least in the near term so for now
consumers will have to adjust to some
rising prices for their breakfast
whether at home or at the diner just
don't forget to include the tip